ele tem que ter aquele livro que decorre
o pessoal do que falar e andar que sejam
muito bem vindos
há mais um período olha só que eu tenho
aqui olha aí eu não quero meu só não
gosta de quebras nilson dong jin dólares
o teto princípios movimento não pode
baixar a cabeça nem isso olha pra mim é
uma coisa que vou fazer é construir uma
casinha pra mim porque tá na colômbia é
muito grande e eu faço ocorre em todo o
lado num canto da sala de edição pelo
canto do meu quarto eu faço xixi na
cozinha e eu não quero dizer que a
campanha própria casa para fazê-lo
cozinho gibbs eu tenho aqui feitas
procurar um erro muitas fitas olha só eu
tenho muitas coisas só tem resulta em um
viaduto em vermelho e azul escuro eu
tenho muitas coisas então vai dar para
construir uma casa muito louco mas esta
questão fitas que dá pra colar o
primeiro tempo construída vai fazer
enfim uma caixa cheia do leve o leite e
por cima das e depois que guardas base
no cantão eu vou colocar isso leque é
pra enfeitar a nossa casinha onde você
não vai estar no inter que tinha mais
nenhum sonho mas mais denso e eu acho
que isso não vai durar a crise mas eu
agora vou colocar aqui no chão falar com
a vida lata de coca-cola eu só faço
coplana sol está a ser uma surpresa
porque fui conhecendo agora foi embora e
nós vamos construir isso tudo em segredo
e eu quero ver a reação dele eu acho que
é sempre a mesma este é um livro como se
fosse um ser humano mas agora o pessoal
primeiro passo não o primeiro passo é o
primeiro passo é vocês deixarem muito
mike neste vídeo é sério isso ajuda
muito que o canal esse componente
crítico no final quem escreveu num só
bruno chega para lá construir a casa do
livro básico é o primeiro passo então
vai ser fazer um molde em cartão
[Música]
op está a casa do pessoal claro que num
filme que derrotar o papel futuro isso é
muito chato mas é assim vai ficar a
cozinha e logo essa é a parte da frente
aí terei esta medida não é para trás
mais ou menos assim ea largura vai ser
esta
olha aí é uma casa já muito grande por
eu ser uma mansão e agora é só colar com
fita adesiva e montar a estrutura lá
hora de construção cabelo cai agora
falta para trás
será que eu vou conseguir ler o bar fica
muito louca eu acho que a gente faz pra
eu realmente tem que ser vencer muito
província ai meu deus eu acho que está
aqui é que está na sua cozinha completa
vou tentar entrar lá dentro está aí eu
vou entrar com já entrou na cabeça mas
eu escolhi um carro agora sim vamos dar
muita coisa que a casa do ministro é
porque eu vou ficar assim cartão é união
servirá como a equipe também tem uma
casa bonita também
estou muito espaço
[Música]
já tinha espaço e mike e agora vamos lá
ver como é que isso funciona olha só o
vínculo muito grande querendo bonito
foi isso que tem uma como já olha sou
gordinho hoje é muito satisfatório é
muito a rodada ram
ok eu vou tirar aqui tudo pelo o plantio
só vocês podem tomar essas peças em
qualquer lugar época qual é muito forte
inclusive aqui no cartão é ico lousa e
agora ela espera que uma pecinha blake
só pra ver se encaixa o cachorro meu não
está muito louco e agora com vocês sabem
calcular nós vamos ficar aqui muito
tempo a construir esse tempo vai durar é
uma cozinha inteira pra forrar a medida
for evoluindo e vamos mostrar veja só
como é que está a ficar é a primeira
fechada aqui da frente está quase pronta
ou então não porque ainda falta muito e
que mexe olha só essa aí como é que nós
temos que fazer o controle em toda preta
a lei fica bem cartune agora é só
continuar
olha só a primeira feijoada completa
olha isso deu muito trabalho
procuraremos muita fita kikwit da
popular tudo aqui lei realengo
falta muita coisa porque deixa claro que
está quase pronto e já está completo
falta ainda para trás o operado e em um
gesto para trás e eu espero que mais
morte nem uma coisa neste valer a pena
para lá vai lá vai lá vai
[Música]
mais uma parede compro é uma eleição
muito bonito e agora falta o telhado
para trás ea outra parede atrás meu
estado muito trabalho servis vagão de
pena e união vai ficar contente
[Música]
pessoal vejam só como é que vai ficar a
casa estava muito pesada olho aí tem
muito lobo já em cima mexe ainda
faltando mais de uma hora de trabalho
porque ainda temos computar esta por ele
e outro atrás
ae mas vamos conseguir um quarto sujo
pessoal nos compõem a nossa missão no
nepal nilson nelson nem isso pessoal
nós concluímos a nossa missão que é
fazer uma que só se pronuncia olha só
este a mansão doença ae
[Música]
toda a superfície da casa está forrada
com a marca olha só olha aí ficou
difícil muito pesado e hoje sou eu
estava muito pesado cérebro e encaixou
muito bem eu vou circular assim alguns
fãs espalhados
o
e agora pessoal vamos lá ver se meu
sangue vai estar da sua nova casa e não
sei se ele está no meu jeito em fazer
uma melhor dentro de uma piscina aqui
dentro da china
eu acho que nem tomar banho olha eu não
sei que o meu técnico olha só em cada
pequeno trio muse sai de casa pois ela
consegue escapar
isso porque eu tenho uma surpresa para
mim quando eu falo que eu não vejo nada
que tenha construído uma casinha para a
equipe da casa que precisa eu sempre
tive um cachorrinho que está muito feliz
lá em casa mexe eu compreendo a casa é
muito grande pra mim é assim então vamos
guardar surpresas foram a 32 um pai
[Música]
este por casa nilson meu sangue é por
causa do meu som
estou incrédulo eu acho que eu acho que
eu estou enganada
nilson por favor eu já sei como é o caso
de donos da casa ganharam machucar eu
possa conhecer a casa é uma casa e
curtir a que entrar lá dentro lá dentro
no centro de campos costa nilson eu acho
que o nosso dever de casa e nem sensual
eu acho que essa missão foi concluída
com sucesso mas começando gosto da casa
já está vivendo dentro falei isso é já
jantou dentro da casa
eu era só um universo eu acho que o
único que janta de manhã
esta união o cachorro pinpoo o cachorro
mais disposto ontem que o senhor que
traça motivada eu consiga ter uma vida
melhor mas chapa união nesta casa eu
acho que estou a adorar a casa
principalmente tudo comida dentro dela
mas acredita como eu quando vim visitar
esta casa continuou frigorífico sheik
ficou 11 após comer um carinho eu vou
tentar roubar a comida ou mesmo da
galiza como tudo só que tem o que vocês
acham comissão gostou da casa assunto
não gostou porque sinceramente eu não
sei por que o porto só está ali pelo
clube
o time não fosse mentiroso pessoal eu
acho que conheço na final gostou porque
ela agora está num nível antigamente
seria do meu corpo e ela agora está aqui
meu sangue está afinal não eu estou acho
que eu estou calmo promoção longe dos
vícios bem pra mim outra vez newsan não
quer saber o que é isso mesmo mas já só
espero que vocês tenham gostado aqui
deste vídeo eu agora vou passar o meu
tempo todo hoje a limpar esta sala vejam
só como está meu mas valeu a pena porque
o cãozinho foi show por uma travessa
chip é ainda assim mais filmes mas é só
deixei muito mais que nos pediu isso
ajuda muito que o canal e inscritos na
frente crédito e já sabem que se tiverem
imaginei que professam comentei que eu
posso fazer é explicar e vai até a
próxima
[Música]